Vsauce. Today we're gonna be covering a topic that is very close to my heart.
Clever uses of YouTube's technologies.
Now, I've always had a lot of fun messing around with stuff like the loading c...
circle and annotations.
But,
let's take a safari today through
things other YouTubers have done. Other
creative ways they've come up with using
what YouTube offers. Now obviously in this
one video we can't cover everything, so
please,
leave in the comments below other cool
things you found other YouTubers
doing. We're gonna start things off with Skittles' touch. These videos are pretty new,
but they let you physically get involved,
or at least with your
finger. I won't ruin the ending to that one,
but I also like the cage cop
version. Your finger helps fight crime.
By the way, there are links to all of these
videos for your own enjoyment
in the description. Back when YouTube
first supported widescreen, freddiew celebrated
by
interacting with the site itself.
He fought
and murdered the very letterboxing
surrounding him.
Joe Sabia has built a lot of really awesome clever things.
He's the guy who made the Oscar's 'Spot the
difference' video where you have to have a
eye
and find the differences and click the
answer to keep moving on
and on and on.
Joe also made this brilliant slot machine
where you have to click each wheel at just the right time
to complete a character.
MysteryGuitarMan was behind this
super creative interactive piano, where you could
make him play a song,
but I think the first person to explore
this fun idea was kokokaka
and play the piano.
In videos like these you have to let the whole
thing load and then you click on the actual piano keys
and they move you to the time code where that note is played.
I'm also a huge fan of this interactive
bass guitar because you can play the
notes
by just typing the numbers on your keyboard.
For instance, here I am using
this sequence to play a little song.
But let's stop playing around and get
narrative. There are a lot of great choose
your join adventure stories on YouTube,
but one of my favorites is Lego Spider,
where you help get a spider
off of your friend's head.
The music, by the way, is just incredible.
But if music and dancing is all you want,
go with the mixable dancer.
It's simple, but something about the costume and the dark background makes it
just crazy enough.
If you prefer magic, be sure to check out
the old classic YouTube magic card trick,
if you haven't already.
It was made back when YouTube first
implemented annotations.
The famous street fighter stop-motion
game from Patrick Boivin
was actually the inspiration behind my
Chris Brown punch out game. You have to
give it a try.
All of those idea used a lot of annotations,
but MysteryGuitarMan took it in a
different direction by including
hidden annotations in his videos that
viewers had to scavenger hunt to find
to get secret words.
Boone Oakley took it one step
even further.
They're an ad agency whose actual website
is a YouTube video. The links on the side here navigate you around and they even
have arrows hard-wired into the video
that show you where to drag the play-head to see specific things.
Now it's your turn.
Remember any fun tricks or
cool ideas that some other YouTuber did
that wasn't covered here? Well,
let us know in the comments below
or post those videos to Facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
I'm talking cool contests, nifty ways to get guys involved or just
other surprising uses of the
technology. I wanna see more of these things,
so let us now.
And as always,
thanks for watching.